ah
lo primero que les quiero pedir es que
la gente que está aquí presente ya los
que nos están viendo en línea tomamos un
respiro super profundo y lento
y seguro que si el resto de lo que les
voy a compartir no es de mucha utilidad
para ustedes al menos haber respirado ya
lo fue y por qué es empezar con esto
porque estoy seguro que vivimos de prisa
yo vivo de prisa a lo mejor muchos de
ustedes también y se les olvida respirar
sobre todo se nos volvía a respirar
lento y profundamente
soy una persona super bendecida 246 años
soy casado
ya casi lo 20 de tengo dos hijas
adolescentes tengo una empresa
la vida me hizo llegar con una
configuración artística y desde muy niño
me tengo las capacidades de ser muy
sensible y contar lo que veo a través
del arte de la música y la pintura
principalmente
he viajado en mi época 2
talleres y pláticas y proyectos con
muchas empresas y en muchos países
lo interesante aquí es que estas
bendiciones o estos privilegios que
tengo
los he empezado a saborear apenas hace
y esto es porque me la pasé creyendo
cosas muy dolorosas sobre mí por mucho
tiempo
qué fue lo que cambió la bolsa se están
preguntando qué le pasa porque hace unos
meses luego que hace unos años unos tres
años empecé con una transición la vida
es aprendizaje lo finalmente siempre
estamos aprendiendo pero hace unos tres
años el aprendizaje se volvió intensivo
de cuenta que pasé a otro nivel no sé si
a otro nivel como de posgrado oa otro
nivel de profundidad o de intensidad me
queda claro
2018 en mayo tengo bien clarito cuando
empezó
les cuento que fue pasando pero algo que
ya terminó de florecer o que termine de
abrazar hace unos meses
y le deje de tener miedo a la muerte
principalmente a mi muerte
todos en muchos momentos hemos escuchado
la conversación o la frase que tiene que
ver con que tú cuando te diste cuenta
que existe la muerte no sé me acuerdo en
quinto de primaria me dijeron para ir a
darle el pésame a un compañero de la
primaria porque había fallecido su papá
y ahí me di cuenta que la muerte existía
pero la de otros
y recuerdo ver la tristeza de la gente
que estaba ahí
de mi compañero obviamente por dulce
electro y comprendí que existía la
muerte ya me habían hablado de ella pero
ay dije ah no si es verdad
pero todavía me tardé mucho tiempo en
ver que esa fuerte me podía alcanzar a
mí
ni siquiera a mí a mis seres queridos
hoy no le tengo miedo a mi muerte
y lo que por mucho tiempo en dónde
estuve
enojado
y apresurado
en el fondo reflexionando bien esque
tenía miedo de irme en un momento no
habiendo dado mi mejor esfuerzo sino el
mejor esfuerzo para calificaciones o
dinero o proyecto
mi mejor esfuerzo para amarme a mí y
para tratar mejor a la gente
y no a lo desconocido sino que lo más
fácil
seres queridos a lo más cercano
con este cambio de paradigma
empezaron a cambiar muchísimas cosas
la sucesión de eventos que pasaron desde
el 2018
repentinamente muere una prima de mi
edad mi hija adolescente tiene un
accidente en un ojo
se ha llevado a otra operación
muere mi suegro
entra al país
mi esposa y yo nos separamos unos meses
y un tío está en coma porque se queda de
una muerto
40 años anduvo en moto y nunca le pasó
nada
le digo se puso intensivo a la cosa no
todo esto lo sabes vez en películas
todos los documentales que hay ahorita
sobre sobre pilotos sobre artistas que
se vulneran y hablan de lo que pasan hoy
como les caen los 20 pero todo el tiempo
y si eso le pasa a otros déjame aprendo
leo libros como cursos pero luego voy a
dar mi mejor esfuerzo
para esta plática nos dicen que en 15
minutos tenemos que pronunciarnos los
tratamos de prepararnos y hacer nuestro
mejor esfuerzo
como nos preparamos y hacemos el mejor
esfuerzo para los 15 minutos de vida que
tenemos
15 años 80 años
27 años 46 años no sé
pero el tiempo limitado vivimos esta
ficción en donde yo sé que me voy a
morir
pero al mismo tiempo pero se ve eterno
sobre todo en la adolescencia y en la
juventud
como me fui cambiando el cuento que me
voy contando yo creo que el primero que
me contéis me duró mucho tiempo y me
privo de darme cuenta de otras cosas
antes
fue que el haber sido el primero de la
fila desde primaria y el más chiquito
me hizo no creo que darme cuenta que
quería ganar tenía que ganar mentalmente
no iba a ser físicamente iba a batallar
mucho no tuve que ver yo cinta negra
para segundo tercero de primaria o un
salvaje sin piedad no me fui por ahí
aparte que me operaron me quitaron la
vesícula en segundo de primaria y eso me
dejó sin recreo y sin hacer deporte y
sin salir a la calle en los meses donde
enfoque en ganar y que nadie se burlaba
de mí y entender la razón me duró un
rato tenemos eeuu y desafíe lo que son
los estereotipos y los prejuicios
de la comunidad en donde crecí
pero en lugar de empezar a ser más libre
me empecé a transformar en personajes
ahora venía ya este niño enojado de
demostrarle a todos que yo tenía la
razón yo tenía la última palabra
y me disfracé de mis
ídolos del mundo de la música y me
presenté de actores me presenté al mundo
cuando como un golpe no si no mitad un
personaje mitad de seguro lópez en la
búsqueda
eso que mantenía enojado todo el tiempo
si me pasaba algo desafortunado la
reacción era enojo
digo en terapia no para entender y como
sanar los enojos y perdonar me encanta
que ahorita el terapeuta con el que
estoy trabajando lo primero que me dijo
es y yo tengo mi terapeuta sigo en
terapia
reconoce su fragilidad reconoce que
sigue avanzando no se presenta como el
gurú el coach que ya terminó
el tema fue que buscando la libertad y
después de estudiar economía en una
institución privada prestigiosa
ahí estoy
dando un paso para demostrar que puedo
ser una persona normal y pertenecer a la
sociedad cuando me di cuenta que no era
por ahí a mí lo que me interesaba era la
educación en duda me voy a vivir a una
playa
quien ahora es mi esposa vivía en
barcelona en ese momento y para cuando
nos casamos y fuimos papás y queríamos
dedicarnos a la educación yo seguía con
esa herida abierta de estar enojado
de sentirme el más chiquito del grupo de
sentirme que tenga que tener la última
palabra que había leído todos los libros
el que podía memorizar se los diálogos
de películas que te hacían pensar y que
se ponían la piel chinita
y cuando eso no pasaba me enojaba y
cuando fui esposo y papá me sentí
desafiado me enojaba
y ahí pasé a dar un segundo segundo
episodio del cuento que me contaba
que era cuando un hombre se enoja se
vale levantar la voz se vale pegarle a
la mesa y se vale parar y decir ya no
las aguanto y salir
totales para tanto
hugo es un muchacho muy responsable es
un buen muchacho saca buenas
calificaciones en el cuadro de honor
tiene trabajo tiene muchos amigos que lo
quieren dicen muchas cosas buenas de él
y lo estaba contando todo el tiempo para
solapar de las acciones para tanto
yo no estoy haciendo tanto daño
este es mi mejor versión es más déjame
me hecho unas cuantas llaves déjenme
unos cuantos mezcales déjame me desvelo
déjame a las 2 34 de la mañana busco con
quién más seguir tocando a ver a qué bar
voy seguro me encuentro a alguien me
subo al escenario a bajar al otro que
tiene su momento
yo soy el protagonista si es tú eres el
protagonista de tu vida pero la película
no es la única película en este planeta
es en sí misma
solapaba el daño que hasta hace unos
años me empecé a dar cuenta
que cause en mi casa en mi familia la
mirada de mi esposa y de mis dos hijas
ahora adolescentes en donde la más
grande fue la primera en replicar mis
berrinches de ese niño chaparrito que
tiene que tener la razón
y mi esposa con todo su amor y toda su
esperanza hacia mí de que yo vi tu
corazón yo sé que hay adentro hay
alguien con quien decidido apostarle
envejecer y ser compañero de esa persona
entonces ese cuento que me estaba
consultando constante de no es para
tanto empezó
a crear un espejo nítido y el clarito
enfrente de mí a través de los
comportamientos y las reacciones de mis
hijas
y de la distancia y la tristeza y el
dolor de mi esposo
mientras yo andaba viajando por el mundo
atendiendo con consultoría en el
aprendizaje y en transformación de
cultura a grandes empresas
e ironía no hablando con dueños de
empresas
directores generales equipos directivos
para decirles que fueran congruentes que
fueran transparentes
y rindan cuentas de sus actos que den la
cara
ante las consecuencias qué
sus acciones detonan
yo llegaba a la casa y el niño reinó en
donde aquí las reglas son las mías pero
criticaba a la gente que se presentó de
una manera muy autoritaria porque no a
mí me gusta yo soy medio hippie
yo soy relax yo soy humanista y yo leo a
ella hace mucho a broma el arte de amar
etc
el tema es que cuando el espejo se te
pone enfrente es difícil
no hay suficientes sustancias o alcohol
o agresiones o antros o pláticas
superficiales
a ignorar ese espejo
estando yo en brasil en un proyecto me
habla mi hermano me dice hugo
nuestra prima repentinamente un error
médico murió mi prima favorito
a los 34 meses a las 11 de la noche nos
hablan y me dicen
hubo ouija tuvo un accidente en uno
a los
cinco meses
le diagnostican cáncer a mi suegro y
fallece en 4
a los
seis meses se viene la pandemia
a los tres meses mi hija adolescente no
soporta estar en la casa
y con el carácter que yo tengo
imagínense como todo es renovado y
aumentado no
ya los trapitos tantos meses en es
posible tenemos que tomarnos un break
hoy en día lo que veo es
una vida llena de colores
porque número uno aprendí a estar solo
estuve ocho meses poco menos de ocho
meses
viviendo en mi oficina que es como una
quinta gran privilegio regalo de dios
si no he tenido eso y tengo que rentar
un departamento porque aparte el negocio
tuvo varios golpes financieros con lo de
la pandemia no sé qué hubiera pasado
pero aprendí a escucharme a verme a
empezar a contar la terapeuta cosas
nuevas que no le contaban porque antes a
los terapeutas que tenía era todo el
tiempo lo que pasa es que ella es que
mis padres es que mis hijas es que el
presidente es que la corrupción la
cultura la idiosincrasia latinoamericana
todo el tiempo hacia afuera
y cuando me decían y cómo te sentías era
como cuando mi papá me preguntaba con mi
hijito pero te puedes estar chaparrito y
yo declaró que no es cuando el terapeuta
me preguntaba pero que no has perdonado
no yo tengo todo perdonado
como tratas a otros no yo los trato muy
bien entonces cuento que me contaba en
el cuento que le contaba y obviamente no
tenía ayuda
aprendí a estar solo a escucharme
diferente en estar callado a no poner ni
música ni leer ni escribir ni pintar ni
estar con gente
a no tomar para alejarme y
ausentarme
y de repente me quedé nada más por mi
voz
me sigo contando cuestas obviamente todo
el tiempo
nuestra mente está funcionando y se está
diciendo tu percepción de la realidad
el tema es que hoy tengo una percepción
mucho más nítida más honesta y sobre
todo llena de amor muy con mucho amor
al trabajar con empresas que es lo que
pasa que veo las interacciones que
tienen
en donde hay individuos
que están haciendo su esfuerzo por ser
mejores
como yo lo estaba haciendo hay padres de
familia
que tratan de proveer van y trabajan y
tratan de ser los mejores para sus hijos
y comprendernos y hay empresarios hay
instituciones hay organizaciones
políticas que
lideran crean e impactan
el tema es que
y esto no viene desde el amor si el
dueño de la compañía tiene condiciones
en donde la gente no tiene tiempo para
estar con su pareja con sus hijos donde
la mayor parte del dinero se la lleva el
accionista y él si yo quiero que vean el
promedio de sueldos que haya diferencia
entre ellos
y la persona que está en la línea
operando
existe estadística es ridícula
impresionante
pero hablemos el capitalismo consciente
y humanismo pero no se cierra esa brecha
los padres de familia no van a estar más
temprano más tranquilos los fines de
semana sin perseguir el número para
saber quién quiénes son como compañeros
y tiene su hijo el joven el niño el ya
adulto
que siente y que está tratando de
compartir su viaje y que eso a la vez
permite individuos que verdaderamente se
pueden hablar con más sinceridad y amor
propio en lugar de estar demostrando que
tienen que seguir en el cuadro de honor
que tienen que ganar el número que
tienen que pasar de gerencia director y
de director a vicepresidente y
vicepresidente a presidente y lo bueno
es que en esta tríada no hay quien tiene
que empezar primero es multidireccional
mejores empresas pueden hacer mejores
padres de familia que estén presentes
para crear a mejores hijos y así pueden
agarrar primero el 2 primero el 1 y cómo
se impactan mutuamente sólo así podremos
tener un mundo como el que más
imaginamos como el que soñamos y que
queremos no importa luego lo hago total
tengo
mucho tiempo para dar mi mejor esfuerzo
me doy cuenta que no tenemos idea así
como ya pasaron estos quince minutos
allá afuera no tenemos idea de cuándo se
acaban los quince minutos
y hoy decido amarme y abrazarme con
todos con todo
vivir completamente desde el amor para
mi esposa para mis hijas para mis
clientes y para cualquiera con el kiel
interactivo bendiciones infinitos para
todos ustedes